[Music]
growing up on a reality show competing
was very stressful Maddie Ziegler has
come a long way since starring on the
Lifetime reality TV series Dance Moms
her popularity is on the rise and she's
the epitome of success but the road to
stardom hasn't always been an easy one
and Maddie's childhood is filled with
dark truths and surprising moments keep
watching to find out what really went
down on the set of Dance Moms young and
famous it's no secret that being under
the public eye is a super stressful
ordeal people follow you around seek you
out in a crowd take pictures of you and
publish faulty articles for your views
being a famous adult is hard enough as
it is
but being a famous kid can be even more
challenging Maddie Ziegler was only
eight years old when she first appeared
on Dance Moms
her whole life revolves around dance and
her life took a drastic turn right off
the bat at first being famous sounded
like a whole lot of fun but soon enough
the Ziegler's realized that fame came
with a price
when Mackenzie had a definitely rocky
childhood the dark side of social media
during an interview with cosmopolitan
Melissa Ziegler opened up about the dark
side of social media and how detrimental
it can be for young children not only
were Mackenzie and Maddie bullied online
but some internet trolls took things to
a whole new level by pretending to be
them on different platforms on top of
that the Ziggler sisters were constantly
subjected to negative comments and
criticism which can seriously affect
young kids who are still learning to
harness healthy levels of self esteem
because she was always compared against
me in hopes of preventing any mental
trauma Melissa made it a point to hire a
social media manager once her girls
started to get popular constant bullying
it's being bullied online wasn't bad
enough both Maddie and Mackenzie were
bullied on the set of Dance Moms while
many of us are quick to point a finger
at Abby Lee Miller whose teaching
methods are absolutely questionable
think about it avi wasn't the only
contributor since Maddie was Abby's
go-to dancer many of the dance moms saw
fit to talk about her behind her back
worst of all was the fact that Maddie
often overheard the adults fighting and
her name was dropped more often than not
this did nothing for Maddie's confidence
levels private tutors since being a part
of the Dance Moms cast was so demanding
many of the girls had to forego a normal
childhood
Maddie's freaking out because we're not
allowed to ice skate and that included
going to school like other kids their
age a normal day in Maddie's life
consisted of being followed around by
cameras she attended normal public
school for about three and a half hours
a day only to rush to the ALDC to start
shooting the reality TV show on top of
that Maddie attended dance class nearly
every single night and when her schedule
became too hectic a private tutor was
brought in to teach the girls in an
office down the road from the studio
she's homeschooling so that the mother
can get her here no time to be kids
since going to public school like normal
children was out of the question Maddie
didn't have a chance to make friends
outside of the studio
so we're world literally revolved around
the ALDC on top of that every minute of
Maddie's life was accounted for going to
birthday parties or kicking back with
the girls on a Saturday night just
wasn't permitted instead Maddie and the
other dancers practiced their dance
numbers day and night from Wednesday to
Friday the girls were in rehearsals and
on Saturdays the girls would compete and
film all day most of the girls only had
Sundays off but even then they had to
study and get ready for the week I was
way more stressed than I am now growing
up too fast not having the time to be a
kid is something that Maddie Mackenzie
and many of the other girls had trouble
with the girls that I don't get to do
fun things as much as we used to do as a
result they grew up too fast and were
subjected to huge amounts of stress
what do you mean you never leave dance
man Maddie Ziegler is far from being a
legal adult but her schedule is loaded
with endorsement deals TV appearances
and tour dates Dance Moms has many dark
truths and subjecting kids to pressure
and making them grow up too fast is just
one of them holds dancers back it's no
secret that Dance Moms is the perfect
platform for a recognition
it's how SIA found Maddie in the first
place when I met her it really just
skyrocketed from there and I'm so
grateful for everything she's given me
but despite helping dancers gain
popularity the reality TV series can
actually hold them back in the long run
during the same interview with
Cosmopolitan Melissa Ziegler talked
about what it really means to have a
contract with the TV series like Dance
Moms in the end her girls received many
offers and opportunities throughout
their time on the show you guys would be
really fantastic
obviously for commercials commercials
are great for kids unfortunately though
they were unable to pursue them due to
their binding contracts so when the
Ziegler's finally decided to call it
quits they were all very happy to be
moving on estranged friendships one of
the best things about Dance Moms is
building close relationships however
Maddie would soon realize that her
longtime friends were bound to the show
when you're a part of the Dance Moms
crew you literally spend all of your
time at the ALDC so once you leave Dance
Moms you don't really get to see your
friends anymore it's just good to think
about our two sisters leaving Maddie was
super close to Kendall and Chloe but
sadly their friendships took a hit after
the Ziggler's left Dance Moms mental
health issues but perhaps the darkest
truth of all is that being a part of the
Dance Moms cast could potentially lead
to mental health issues via Thailand and
Kendall vertes both suffered from
anxiety attacks throughout their time on
the show I feel you know her and many of
the other dancers are reported feeling
overwhelmed and mentally and physically
strained she's a little girl
seven hours of dances a lot since the
show revolves around preteens
competitions yelling and fighting it
would have been a good idea to have a
child psychiatrist on set
unfortunately this just wasn't the case
what do you think is the best and worst
part about being on Dance Moms sound off
in the comments section give this video
a big thumbs up if you love Maddie
Ziegler and don't forget to subscribe to
the themes for the latest Dance Moms
news thanks for watching catch you next
time
[Music]